meet susan an aspiring painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure
as anyone could easily forge or
replicate them
her friend mark came to her rescue with
an idea of nft
he suggested that susan could buy nfts
for all her paintings
as nfts are trustworthy easily
transferable and will also maintain her
ownership rights on her artworks
susan had no idea what nfts were so mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind
by creating a unique digital signature
which defines the ownership of your
assets
and that can be bought and sold for real
money cryptocurrency
or any other asset like a non-fungible
token
aka nft non-fungible tokens means that
they are not interchangeable
and each of them represents unique
assets owned by a specific person
on the other hand fungible tokens are
interchangeable and can be divided into
smaller units to form the same value
for example a one hundred dollar bill is
fungible as you can exchange it with
five twenty dollar bills or two fifty
dollar bills
but the painting of the last supper is
non-fungible as it cannot be generated
in bulk
even if it is copied it will not be
authentic
each nft contains distinguishable
information like who owns the digital
asset
and who sold it making them distinct and
easily verifiable
as it is impossible to forge such a
certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is susan was
curious to know
how exactly nft nft basically creates a
blockchain-based digital certificate for
your digital collectibles
including games music art and many more
this certificate
gives your artwork a unique identity the
underlying technology
and the programming language used by
nfts are the same as other
cryptocurrencies
such as blockchain and the programming
language eth
or script nft majorly exists on ethereum
blockchain
a distributed public ledger that records
all the transactions
however nft is quite different from
these cryptocurrencies
bitcoin and ethereum are fungible tokens
which means if you trade bitcoin or
ethereum for one another
you will have the same value or item in
return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore
if you try to trade it you may end up
with something completely different in
your hands
crypto punks is a remarkable example of
nft
it enables you to buy sell and store 10
000 collectibles with the proof of
ownership being stored on the ethereum
blockchain
after exploring helen ft's work susan
was convinced and bought nfts for all
her paintings
due to this her artworks were secured
from any kind of forgery and also gave
her artworks a particular value
this contributed to increased sales too
as everyone was easily able to buy the
artwork without any fear
all in all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others
like jack dorsey the ceo and co-founder
of twitter with his very first and
famous tweet
just setting up my twitter and vignesh
sandarsen
famously known as medicovan who bought
69.3 million dollars worth of nft art on
people
owing to its increasing popularity
people are now willing to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars for
nfts nft has enhanced media exposure
and special perks for aspiring artists
like susan on social media
this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
so here is a question for you what makes
any item non-fungible
a exchangeability b unique digital
signature
c trade-ability d distributed public
ledger
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
many experts in the crypto industry say
that around 40 of new crypto users will
use nfts as their entry point
as a result of its growing popularity
nft could represent a more significant
part of the digital economy
in the future we hope you enjoyed this
video
if you did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell
icon for more on the latest technologies
and trends
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn
you